[موسيقى]
مساء الخير كلام مهم جدا لقائد المنطقه
المركزيه الامريكيه امام مجلس النواب يوم
24 مارس الماضي ماذا قال الجنرال ولماذا
كلامهم مهم جدا ومؤثر علينا في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط هذا موضوع حلقه اليوم ولكن
خلفيه سريعه وباختصار شديد عاد صراع القوى
الكبرى او الحرب البارده التي شهدها
العالم منذ العام 1947 وحتى سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي في ديسمبر 1991 لكن هذه المره
الحرب بين الولايات المتحده وحلفائها من
جانب والصين وروسيا من جانب اخر هدف الصين
شق طريقها ان لم يكن لقياده العالم فعل
الاقل للحصول على فرصه للنبوه والازدهار
كقوه كبرى هدف الولايات المتحده ببساطه
القضاء على اي احتمال لتفوق الصين عليها
في كل الوسائل وشعار الامريكان اما الان
او فات الاوان ايفر
اعتقاد الامريكان انهم اذا لم يتمكنوا
الان من وقف النمو الصيني والصعود الصيني
فسوف تتجاوزهم الصين وتتفوق عليهم ويصبح
الامريكان قوه من الدرجه الثانيه
في هذا الصراع تلعب منطقه الشرق الاوسط
دورا كبيرا جدا كما لعبت دورا كبيرا جدا
اثناء الحرب البارده من 47 ل 91 لماذا
ببساطه لحاجه القوتين الى هذه المنطقه في
اداره الصراع فيما بينهم ببساطه جدا الصين
بتعتمد بشكل رئيسي على وارداتهم من الطاقه
من هذه المنطقه لتغذيه اقتصادها وقوتها
العسكريه بدون بترول منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لن يكون هناك تفوق صيني اقتصادي ولا تفوق
صيني عسكري
امريكا تدرك ذلك جيدا وتخطط لحرمان الصين
من امدادات الطاقه القادمه من الشرق
الاوسط في حال اندلع الصراع كل هذا ليس
جديدا الجديد ان ذلك او هذا التخطيط او
هذا التفكير لم يعد سرا وان المسؤولين
وليس المحللين الامريكان يتحدثون عن ذلك
علنا وبلا مواربه يتحدثون عن اهميه الشرق
الاوسط ومجاره المائيه لخنق الصين التي
يعتمد اقتصادها بشكل اساسي على البترول
الذي ياتي من هذه المنطقه في حال دلع
الصراع هذا تطور مهم وخطير ومخيف على
الاقل لنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ان نكون
جزءا من
ساحات الصراع الاولى بين الصين والولايات
المتحده اذا اردتم مثالا فليس هناك اوضح
ولا افضل مما قاله الجنرال مايكل
اللي هو قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
والذي يتبلى والذي يتولى مهمته منذ ابريل
الجنرال استدعى الى استدعى لمجلس النواب
او طلب يعني للحضور امام مجلس النواب
الامريكي يوم 24 مارس الماضي
للحديث عن الموقف العسكري الامريكي
وتحديات الامن القومي في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا
فتحدث الجنرال باستفاضه امام مجلس النواب
وبالمناسبه بسبب اهميه ما قاله انا اضع
هذه الافاده لحضراتكم لمزيد من الاطلاع
اسفل الحلقه فيه ثلاثه اشكال اولا نص
الافاده مكتوبه النص الافاده التي قدمها
الجنرال مجلس النواب ثانيا او نص ما قاله
اللي بيختلف اللي هو نفس مضمون ما كتبه
ولكن بيختلف فقط في الصياغه
ثالثا نص المقابله الصوت وصوره من خلال
فيديو يمكنك الاطلاع عليه ضمن مصادر
الحلقه
لكن خلاصه ما قاله الجنرال انه في حاله
حدوث صراع بين الصين والولايات المتحده
يمكن للقياده المركزيه الامريكيه او
القياده الوسطى يعني توجيه القوات
العسكريه الامريكيه لقطع تدفقات شحنات
الطاقه القادمه من المنطقه الى الصين
وبالتالي حرمانها من الطاقه اللازمه
لتغذيه التها الانتاجيه واهلتها العسكريه
وقال نصا جود
اذا لا سمح الله
اندلع الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
سنكون قادرين على التحكم في الكثير من
اقتصادهم
وتعريضه للخطر من خلال منطقه القياده
المركزيه وبالمناسبه مقر الاسطول الخامس
اللي هو بيمثل القوات البحريه في للقياده
المركزيه مقره البحرين ما هي القياده
المركزيه عندها افرع مختلفه جيش كامل
متكامل قوات بحريه وقوات جويه وقوات بريه
الى اخره مقر الاسطول الخامس اللي هو
القوات البحريه التابع للقياده المركزيه
مقره مملكه البحرين
واستعرض قائد المنطقه المركزيه وزملاء
اخرين له في البنتاجون مدى قوه الجانب
الامريكي او الحضور العسكري الامريكي في
المنطقه مقارنه بخصومهم اللي هم الصين
وروسيا على النحو التالي وباختصار ايضا
كانت الولايات المتحده ولعشرات السنوات
الماضيه هي القوه المهيمنه في المنطقه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط الكثير من دول المنطقه
متحالف بشكل وثيق مع الامريكان
كثير من هذه الدول بيعتمد على المساعدات
العسكريه والاقتصاديه الامريكيه عدد من
هذه الدول بيستضيف قواعد عسكريه امريكيه
على اراضيه
ينتشر اكثر من 30 الف جندي في هذه اللحظه
في المنطقه وعليه فان البنتاجون قادر على
في اي لحظه النشر السريع لقوات كبيره
امريكيه كبيره لتنضم للقوات الموجوده
بالفعل وبالتنسيق مع شركائنا الامريكان
افتح قوسين زي ما هو بيقول يعني مستفيدين
من عشرات السنوات من التعاون العسكري مع
حلفائنا هناك لمواجهه اي طوارئ والمقصود
بالطوارئ في هذا السياق طبعا هو مواجهه
عسكريه مع الصين كيف يمكن استخدام منطقه
الشرق الاوسط كسلاحا ضد الصين ببساطه بمنع
تدفق البترول والغاز
الذي ياتي من المنطقه الى الصين وبيشرح
الجنرال اهميه المنطقه من حيث الطاقه الى
الصين بيقول انه طبعا هو لم ياتي بجديد
يعني في ذلك هو بيقرر ما هو قائم ويعرفه
الجميع انه المنطقه في الوقت الحالي
بتنتج 37 في المئه من النفط العالمي
لكنها تحتوي على ما يقرب من نصف احتياطات
النفط المعروفه في العالم واكثر من اربعين
في المئه من غازي الطبيعي هذه المواد التي
تتدفق من المنطقه الى خارجها بتمر عبر
مجموعه من نقاط العبور او المضايق البحريه
وهم واهم هذه المضايق ثلاثه قناه السويس
باب المندب ومضيق هرمز وبيشرح الجنرال اي
تعطيل لهذه المعابر او خنقها يؤثر بشكل
كبير على كل البلدان التي تعتمد على نفط
المنطقه وغازها وعلى راس هذه الدول بطبيعه
الحال الصين اللي اوضح انها
تستورد
72% من احتياجاتها من البترول
معظم هذه الاتنين يعني هي بتنتج 28% محليا
وبتستورد 72 في المئه معظم الاتنين في
المئه من الواردات بتاتي من منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وطبعا كانت السعوديه بتحتل رقم
واحد في الصادرات اللي هي الدول المورده
للبترول للصين وكانت العراق ايضا بتحظى
بمركز متقدم في تصدير البترول الى
الولايات للصين وما زال البلدين كذلك
وباقي دول المنطقه ولكن نتيجه ظروف الحرب
بدات الصين تعتمد بشكل اكبر على روسيا في
الفتره الاخيره واصبحت روسيا هي المورد
الاكبر للبترول والغاز الصيني لكن تظل
المنطقه هي يعني مصدر بالغ الاهميه
للصينيين
وبيشرح قائد المنطقه المركزيه بيقول انه
الاتنين وسبعين في الميه من الواردات من
واردات الطاقه الصينيه التي تاتيها من
الخارج ومعظمه من منطقه الشرق الاوسط على
الاقل حتى وقت قصير جدا
98% من هذه الواردات ياتي بحرا يعني عبر
المجاري الملاحيه الدوليه التي يسيطر
عليها
السلاح البحريه الامريكي وتحديدا القوات
المركزيه الامريكيه
وبيضيف ذات كميك
هذا يجعلهم تحت
رحمتنا هذا يجعلهم في موقف ضعيف
وطبيعي بطبيعه الحال سيكون التركيز بشكل
خاص في اي عمل عسكري على مضيق هرمز اللي
هو بيمثل المعبر الرئيسي لكل شحنات النفط
او الطاقه التي تاتي من منطقه الخليج الى
دوله الصين الجنرال اريك بيختم كلامه او
افادته امام المجلس النواب بالتاكيد على
ان القياده الوسطى او القياده المركزيه
الكوماند بعد هذا الاستعراض ستكون بالمعنى
الحرفي والمعنى المجازي
بالمعنى الحرفي هي سنترا اللي هي اسمها
سنترال كوماند وسنترال بالمعنى المجازي
انها بالغه الاهميه في المواجهه والصراع
والمنافسه مع الصين وروسيا ويقول لقد قلنا
هناك في الماضي نحن هنا اليوم وسنكون هناك
في المستقبل انتهى كلام الجنرال وهو كلام
خطير جدا واليكم ملاحظات سريعه يمكن ان
نتحدث عنها بالتفصيل في حلقات مقبله اول
هذه الملاحظات انه تفكير الولايات المتحده
في استغلال حظر النفط او استغلال النفط
كسلاح ضد خصومها ليس امرا جديدا فعلته قبل
ذلك ويمكن جدا ان تفعله بعد ذلك في
المستقبل
السوابق كثيره لكن اهم سابقا كان ما فعلته
الولايات المتحده ضد اليابان قبل الحرب
العالميه الثانيه قد لا يعلم الكثيرون ان
الولايات
المتحده التي كانت قلقه من تحركات اليابان
على مصالحها في منطقه اسيا تحديدا قررت
عقابها قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه بفرض
حظر للنفط الامريكي على اليابانيين
اليابان كانت بتعتمد في احتياجاتها من
الطاقه بنسبه 80 في المئه على البترول
الامريكي
وكثير من المؤرخين او من المتابعين
بيعتقد ان المسؤولين الامريكان لما اتخذوا
هذه الخطوه كانوا يقدرون انها يمكن ان
تقودوا الى حرب بين اليابان والولايات
المتحده وبالفعل بعد هذه الخطوه الامريكيه
لا تصرفت اليابان على مستويين المستوى
الاول انها هاجمت ميناء بيرلا هاربر
وبالتالي دخلت الولايات المتحده او كان
ذلك سببا مباشره لدخول الولايات المتحده
الى الحرب العالميه الثانيه نفتح قوسين
انه هذا بيتناقض مع الروايه اللي بتروج
لها وسائل الاعلام او الهوليود الامريكيه
ان الامريكان بالعدوان الياباني عليهم دون
سابق انذار او مبرر كان هناك مبرر وهو
العمل العدائي من جانب امريكا على الاقل
من وجهه نظر اليابان وهو قطع كل امدادات
البترول عن اليابان الامر الذي اربك
التفكير العسكري والاقتصادي لليابانيين
الامر الثاني طبعا ان اليابان بدات تتصرف
او تاخذ قرارات هدفها اثناء الحرب تامين
مصادر طاقه بديله ودي قصه ممكن نتكلم عنها
في المستقبل
الاحتلال مصادر طاقه في اماكن اخرى مثل
اندونيسيا على سبيل المثال البلد اللي
بتعرف الان باسم اندونيسيا
هذه الملحوظه الاولى
الملحوظه الثانيه ان الصين بتدرج جيدا ما
تفكر فيه الولايات المتحده ليس لانها سمعت
الجنرال اريك يتحدث يوم 24 مارس هي تعلم
ذلك جيدا سواء تحدث عنه الجنرال او لم
يتحدث حديث الجنرال بيصعد من
التوتر بين البلدين لانه اصبح كلاما رسميا
اعلانيا ولكنه لا يضيف جديدا في فهم
تحركات فهم الصين لتحركات الولايات
المتحده الصين تدرك ذلك جيدا وواحده من
ابرز الشواغل الاستراتيجيه للصين في منذ
سنوات طويله ما يعرف بملقا ديلما او ورطه
مضيق ملقى اللي هو مضيق تتحكم او بتمر منه
معظم واردات الصين من الطاقه وغيرها الى
الصين وطبعا معظم صادرات الصين الى العالم
الولايات المتحده تتحكم في هذا المضيق
وبالتالي الحديث عن مضيق ملقى هو تقريبا
رمز او يلخص ازمه الصين في قدره الولايات
المتحده على شل وارداتها وصادراتها اما من
خلال مضيق هرمز بشكل مباشر او المضايق
المختلفه او طبعا مضيق ملقى فالمساله
معروفه وتستعد له على كل المستويات كيف
تستعد له واحد انها بتبحث منذ سنوات على
الاقل من 2013 عن طرق بديله تمر منها
واردات الطاقه التي تاتيها من الخارج
بعيدا عن سيطره الولايات المتحده البحريه
على وجه الخصوص
تحصين هذا الهدف واحد من اهم اهداف مبادره
الحزام والطريق او طريق الحرير اللي هو
عباره عن مجموعه من الطرق اللي بترب الدول
العالم بالصين واحد اهداف ربط العالم
او الاماكن الحيويه للصين بطرق تجاريه هو
تامين مرور الطاقه والمواد الخام من مناطق
مختلفه ومنها منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولكن
بعيدا عن المسارات وخصوصا المسارات
البحريه التي تتحكم فيها القوات الامريكيه
اتنين تعميق العلاقات مع الدول الغير
حليفه مع الولايات المتحده وعلى راسها
طبعا روسيا
وايران كلاهما بلدان معاديان للولايات
المتحده كلاهما بلدان غنيان جدا بالغاز
والبترول والدول الثلاثه بتسعى لي بناء
طرق بديله لتبادل التجاره فيما بينها
بعيدا عن سيطره الولايات المتحده خصوصا
السيطره البحريه
بالتسعه الصين بكل ما اوتيت من قوه لتطوير
قدراتها في توليد الطاقات البديله او
الطاقات الجديده واصبحت اكثر دول العالم
تطورا في انتاج الطاقه الخضراء او الطاقه
النظيفه على امل ان تقل حاجتها للوقود
الاحفوري اللي موجود في مناطق معظمها تحت
سيطره او نفوذ الولايات المتحده اربعه
انها تسعى بكل بقوتات من جهد لتعزيز
وتقويه علاقتها بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط حتى
تحيدها وتبعدها عن
نفوذ الولايات المتحده ولذلك توقعوا في
السنوات المقبله السنوات القليله المقبله
حضورا كبيرا جدا من جانب الصين على امل ان
هي تزود نفوذها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وتقل قدره الولايات المتحده عن استخدام
المنطقه
لحرمان الصين من واردات هذه المنطقه من
البترول
انا وان احنا اتكلمنا عن التاريخ اذكركم
انه الصين الان بتشبه الى حد كبير موقف
اليابان والمانيا قبل الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كلاهما كان بلدان صناعيان مثل
الصين كلاهما كان يحتاجان كميات هائله من
الطاقه لكن داخل حدودهم ما فيش ما يكفي من
الطاقه والطاقه التي تاتي من خارج حدودهم
كانت تحت رحمه الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وده كان احد اهم العوامل اللي حكمت تحركات
اليابان وتحركات
المانيا في الحرب العالميه الثانيه يعني
مثلا التفسير الاساسي للقرار الخطير جدا
الذي اتخذه ادلف هتلر هتلر بغزو الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان سببه رغبته في تامين مصادر
الطاقه الموجوده في الاتحاد السوفيتي
قرار زي ما قلت لحضراتكم اليابان بضرب
بيرل هاربر كان عقابا للولايات المتحده
على حرمانها من البترول الامريكي وامريكا
كانت بتنتج قبل اندلاع الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ثلثي ما ينتجه العالم من البترول
ثم تحركاتها بعد ذلك في كثير من الساحات
الاسيويه وتحديدا
اندونيسيا ما تعرف الان باندونيسيا كان
هدفه تامين مصادر البترول البترول لليابان
الصين في موقف مشابه تحتاج الى كميات
كثيره من البترول كثير من مصادر البترول
خارج حدودها ولذلك تحركاتها السياسيه
والعسكريه في القلب منها تامين مصادر
البترول كما حدث بالنسبه لليابان
وبالنسبه
المانيا قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الملحوظه الثالثه انه
هناك تراجع في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
على الارجح في الشهور المقبله او في
السنوات المقبله كان هناك توجه منذ اداره
اوباما لاعطاء اهميه اقل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط منذ ان اعلن عن سياسته المعروفه
والخلاصتها ان الولايات المتحده توجه كل
قدراتها ومواردها لمواجهه الصين وروسيا في
منطقه اسيا وتخفف من التزاماتها في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وجاء بعده ترامب اتبع نفس
السياسه بدرجات مختلفه يعني وكذلك الرئيس
الحالي بايدن لكن يبدو ان هذه السياسه
كانت مبنيه على فرصه افتراض خاطئ ان انا
ممكن اتخفف من الالتزاماتي في المنطقه
واترك المنطقه يعني كده دون اي التزامات
من جانبي اتجاه دولها وانا امن على مصالحي
تماما يعني اضمن مصالحه باقل قدر من
الاشتباك مع هذه المنطقه اللي هي يعني
منطقه كلها مستنقعات وكوابيس ثبت ان ذلك
كلام فارغ جدا
يكادور ما تقدرش زي المثل الامريكي بيقول
لك تاكل الكيكه وتحتفظ بها اذا اردت ان
تحافظ على مصالحك في هذه المنطقه من
العالم عليك ان تكون متورطا فيها وبالتالي
على الارجح سوف تعيد النظر الولاء سوف
تعيد الولايات المتحده النظر في سياساتها
تجاه المنطقه وتعود اليها مجددا بقوه لكن
وهذه الملحوظه الرابعه ان هناك فرقا كبيرا
جدا بين الرغبه والقدره التغير في
الاستراتيجيه يعني تغير في الرغبه انا
ارغب في ان اتي الى المنطقه لكن هل تستطيع
الولايات المتحده ان تاتي وان يعني
تعطي جله اهتمامها لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
كما كان الحال في الاربعينات والخمسينات
والستينات والسبعينات والثمانينيات هل
تستطيع هذا امر محل شكل ان الولايات
المتحده في هذه السنوات اثناء الحرب
البارده حين كانت امبراطوريه يعني عافيه
جدا ليس هي نفس الولايات المتحده الان
الامبراطوريه المرهقه
لكن كل شيء وارد لكن المؤكد اننا الان سوف
نكون على اعتاب مرحله جديده الشرق الاوسط
بيعيش فصل جديد من تاريخه قدامي المضطرب
يعني في ظل حرب جديده بين القوى الكبرى
ملحوظه الاخيره انه الصين بتشاهد ما تفعله
الولايات المتحده ولديها مجموعه من
الخيارات
اذكركم ان الصين حضرت الى المنطقه منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في السنوات الاخيره وكانت
عازفه عن الحضور لانها كانت تركز على
منطقه اسيا منطقه جوارها المباشر بحر
الصين الجنوبي وجدت انه الرئيس اوباما
سن سياسته المشهوره ووجه كل قواته وكل
قدرات الامريكيه وفعل كذلك ترامب وفعل ذلك
بيضا الى منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي فبدات
تفعل سياسه تعرف باسم السير غرب السير او
مارشتو دواسه او السيرو نحو الغرب والغرب
تقصد به منطقه الشرق الاوسط وكان منطقها
مدام انتم يعني مساله حياه بالنسبه لكم
بحر الصين الجنوبي سنترك ذلك قليلا ونذهب
الى منطقه بالغه الاهميه لنا وهي منطقه
الشرق الاوسط الان الامريكان يرغبون فيه
العوده لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط ربما تغير
السين استراتيجيتها قليلا فتؤمن مصالحها
بقدر ما تستطيع في الشرق الاوسط لكنها
تسعى مجددا للتوسع في منطقه بحر الصين
الجنوبي الامر الذي سوف يكون مربكا
للامريكان ويعني فتح جبهات متعدده امام
الصين لننتظر ونرى ويكون لنا مع هذا
الصراع ودور منطقه الشرق الاوسط في حلقات
اخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى لقاء